[Musique]
c'est simplement du cash qu on va dire
mais qui me sert évidemment faire sandro
maje un simple cache pot en guise
d'aileron pour 7 à quoi sienne jacquet
lui a gardé de son enfance aux malouines
le goût d'utiliser ce qui glanait sur la
plage des coquillages une carapace de
tortue des jouets d'enfants un peu de
l'arte povera on parle de matériaux cher
voilà si je puis dire puisqu'ils sont
ceux qui tombent sous la main ou des
matériaux cassé en règle générale voilà
puis ça permet de recréer la part du
rêve avec ce à quoi ont donc vont se
dire que c'est pas simplement des objets
morts
ces enfants de neptune seront bientôt
embarquer dans le poste de pilotage de
deux vaisseaux long de 25 m ils seront
sur les quais du festival de loire fin
septembre et il reste moins de deux mois
pour finaliser leur assemblage un
travail qui appelle à une douce
régression vers l'enfance
et pas vraiment de plan de montage enfin
ça c'était vraiment un feeling et enfin
voilà le but du jeu c'est de ne pas pas
faire de remplissage ne pas mettre des
choses à des endroits parce que ça fait
joli
le but de ces voix là c'est vraiment de
retomber en enfance et de faire vraiment
comme si on construisait un vaisseau
quoi de voir tiens ça ça peut se
raccorder à ça pourquoi ça peut être le
réacteur enfin voila c'est vraiment
d'essayer de de faire ça au feeling et
de voir qu'est ce qui peut être relié
avec quoi pour que ça une continuité que
et que c'est vraiment l'air d'un d'un
vaisseau quoi quand on veut
travailler un volume consiste ce que
voudrait mettre pour le faire suivre etc
le problème c'est que c'est pas toujours
les matériaux puisque c'est de la récup
donc c'est avant tout je te dévore en
permanence invente ou je te dévore une
expérience artistique à laquelle le
public est invité à participer jusqu'au
2 septembre